we met once and then twice back to back
two dates in london
and then it was i think about
three maybe four weeks later that i
managed to
persuade her to come and join me in
botswana
and we and we we camped out with each
other under the stars
now several years later we're learning
intimate new details about prince harry
and meghan markle's
romantic trips to botswana and how they
fell
in love what was fascinating was just
how quickly things developed and
those beautiful trips to botswana which
were able to retrace within the book and
of course
that second trip to botswana that was
where harry had
first spoken to megan about making his
wife that's finding freedom co-author
omit scooby revealing the moment harry
told megan
she was the one et's michelle turner sat
down with scobee
the day before the book's official
release on august 11.
you worked with harry and megan or did
they give permission for people close to
them
to speak harry and megan didn't take
part in the process of this book or
contribute any interviews but many of
the friends that we approached to speak
to to tell
aside a different side of the story were
so frustrated with some of the coverage
they had seen of their friends
they felt that the people they were
seeing on these pages were not their
friends
not the people that they knew and thanks
to those sources
we're learning what really happened when
harry met
megan it's really interesting that those
um trips to africa were really kind of
the linchpin
significant moments in their
relationship
i think that harry taking megan to
botswana and parts of africa and seeing
how she handled that
being okay sort of out on safari with
just a tent and
i remember saying that she was happy
just to take a pack of baby wipes
uh to clean her face and a backpack very
low
when it came to sort of what she was
what she needed to get through the day
she was sort of happy to wander off
into the forest for a bathroom break
those are the things that i think harry
would have noticed immediately that this
girl
was very much sort of on his level and
what he was about they shared a
substance with each other and
both the love for that same part of the
world as well which has
really united them we spent coming
joining for five days out there which
was absolutely fantastic so
then we were really by ourselves which
was crucial
to me to make sure that we had a chance
to get to know each other
of course there were the critics that
think harry moved too
fast
popping the question to megan a year and
a half after they first met
i don't think that i would call it a
whirlwind uh in terms of our
relationship
my heart swoons at the fact that three
months in
they were saying i love you and in
africa was one of the first times that
happened
my head is saying that's quick that's
really quick
listen harry and megan had both
experienced love
and proper relationships earlier on in
their lives megan of course had been
married before
she knew exactly what it is that would
work and what wouldn't work in a
relationship for her and i think harry
came to the table
with very much that same feeling and so
when they did meet
they did tick all the right boxes with
each other and the connection was strong
it made every sense to move forward from
that and not to look back and i think
while some people
accused them of rushing or thinking that
it was moving too fast
these were two adults well into their
30s that were also aware of the clock
ticking you know they wanted to settle
down and
have a family and i think it just made
perfect sense for it to follow
the path that it eventually did it's no
secret harry's older brother prince
william was one of the biggest critics
there's an important moment in the book
where william sits down with harry
to sort of express some of his own
concerns about the speed at which the
relationship was moving now
that's great brotherly advice and
especially if it was
asked for um but what we have to
remember in the build-up to that that
harry was already aware of some of the
things that were being said about megan
within the institution
he was already aware of some of the
disparaging comments that being made
behind his back by
some of his own friendship circle and so
when william came to him with this
conversation
i can see how it may have come across as
yet another unsupportive individual
at a time when he needed someone to have
his back so you can see how
things may have sort of changed from
that point onwards and
i have heard from sources close to
william that he very much regrets
having that conversation but despite
their differences
scoby is adamant that the brothers
relationship is
on the mend i think it's we make it very
clear in the book that you know
harry had a conversation with a friend
earlier this year
he spoke about the importance of that
bond of brotherhood and how that will
never
disappear from him so whilst we do see
two brothers now
spending time away from each other i
wouldn't call that the end of their
relationship i think that these things
sort of come in waves and
as harry said himself in that interview
in southern africa
that they don't see each other that
often but they're also on very different
paths and i think that those paths will
reconnect them at some point but
it is difficult